a lot of people in America first became
aware of you you were working on a Star
Trek show and at first by your own
admission you would say you had a bit of
a reputation for being maybe a little
uptight on set or a little impossible I
was so boring and tiresome I I had this
thing about discipline and I felt that
the cast my fellow cast members in Star
Trek were a little unruly at times too
many jokes too much fooling around
singing songs so I called a meeting this
was quite early on in the first season
and I said all right look guys you know
we are only here for part of the day
there are a lot of people who are here
all day long every day no matter what we
do and how much time off we have I think
we should think about them and we should
try and get on with the work more often
focus on what we're doing and really
concentrate and keep the days as short
as possible and it was Denise Crosby who
said to me oh Patrick come on we've got
to have some fun and I said we are not
here to have fun
so that guy would not have accepted the
Emoji role
but now it feels like you were I get the
sense and I've had this for a while and
interviewing you you're having a lot of
fun silliest person on the set you now
yeah yeah now yeah that's my that's my
that's what I hope to be voted at the
end of every project yeah silliest actor
on the set and it was all thanks to my
pals in Star Trek who said Patrick for
heaven say come on come on you'll find
you'll enjoy the work more if you have
fun a few laughs every day it'll go
quicker contrary to what you're saying
and of course they were right and we had
a great time so thank you
all those guys because they uh I think
they made me live longer I think maybe I
wouldn't be here if they had not taught
me how to laugh more because I didn't
laugh very much at all and here I said
laugh then yeah why do you think I said
laugh instead of laugh
s
because everyone says laugh and uh yeah
but you're in this country and that's
how it should be said
you're not Charles Lawton
well no I wish sometimes I wear I mean
my wife says to me let's let's I'll tell
you what let's go for a walk on the talk
and I say I'm sorry I walk on a talk
what the heck is that you mean a walk
and a talk
it never I do like the way you say it
back thank you it is better